c'est William le prince William et Kate
Middleton ils sont dans leur chambre à
coucher et Ken
[Applaudissements]
dans la chambre à coucher
et il faut savoir que le prince William
il a un petit truc qu'il adore faire ça
dans le noir le noir le plus complet ah
celui qui en a un peu marre il y a
quelques mois bah elle a décidé d'ouvrir
la lumière et là si tu portes
tremblement qu'est-ce qu'elle voit qu'en
réalité bah William il utilise un
sextoys
pourquoi est-ce que tu fais ça il faut
que tu m'expliques
je vais t'expliquer le sex toys et toi
tu vas m'expliquer notre adresse
voilà
c'est la première fois que le début
d'une blague est plus drôle que la chute